hi are you interested in the PewDiePie
channel the biggest channel on YouTube
much better than Jack speed icd just as
this random person subscribe today for
free you can become bro
[Music]
we're gonna go through some commercials
I know
great idea I've looked for the worst and
weirdest commercials on the Internet I
thought we'd check them out see how bad
can you be how bad can it be I think
we've all watched just some random the
ones you call in commercials during that
place during the day you have nothing to
do you're just sitting at home there's
nothing to watch on television and
you're just watching this thing
on TV where they're trying to sell you
some shitty product and you're like I
don't know why I'm watching this but I'm
watching it and you know what it's
actually kind of entertaining I'm not
gonna but you know what I might even buy
that and you buy it and use it once
and the rest is history well those kind
of commercials we're gonna check out
today so here we go as I always say
millions of women like yourself suffer
from just like me thank you for not
excluding the man a poor night's rest
sleeping on your side without proper
breast support can be a major culprit I
will say yes actually it is it is a big
problem for me to sleep on the side for
my breasts as a man thank you
introducing cush
introducing weed the comfortable
nighttime companion anatomically
contoured to gently support and cushion
the weight of a woman's breasts cush
maintains a more natural oh no garments
need it the slippers it how did you not
see what was wrong with this sticking a
long object between your tits how did
you did no one just think hey maybe just
maybe that's like it looks a little
weird this helps keep cushion place even
as you roll from side to side push
offers comfort and proper spine
alignment for side sleepers pregnant
women nursing mothers and post-operative
recovery I want to ask right now it's a
little awkward question but if you have
a seat cup or larger it's just a problem
it's just a problem I'm genuinely
curious as a d-cup I I mean as a b-cup I
don't I don't know what to say holy
oh I guess they went out of business
no no not kosher support
god damn it over 100 years we've been
scrunching and folding toilet paper a
hundred years guys we've been wiping her
ass with toilet paper finally there's a
better way come down wipe the sanitary
paper extension arm and holder the first
improvement a toilet paper as we know it
since the 1880s it the first improvement
since the 1880s what happened in the
1880s extend your reach a full 18 inches
it's as easy to use as a shower brush oh
that's disgusting dude you're not gonna
use it as a shower brush pop on the
toilet tissue and went through just
press the release button and the tissue
drops right into the toilet my god think
about it toilet paper is really archaic
and disgusting I have never thought
about that Danny have you thought of
Emma have you thought about that how
chaotic and disgusting it is actually
she doesn't make a point like a this
kind of gross how how near your hand is
to your anus but I mean you do you do
wash your hands
towards you you do do that do you that's
right never touch another dirty toilet
tissue yeah big guy certainly has its
advantages and its disadvantages oh dude
no what do you say being a big guy
certainly has its advantages and its
disadvantages
ah Comfort wipe the sanitary paper
extension arm and holder the first
improvement who wants to stick that up
their ass raise your hand I think I got
like the budget budget version of this I
got that just ain't the standard bottom
wiper I guess we didn't get there that
deluxe one but whatever we'll we'll try
it we'll try and see if it's good you
got him remain optimistic
this is anatomically designed oh that's
strong its strong like a Swedish man oh
I'm gonna break it alright so I have
some toilet paper I guess I guess I have
to wipe my ass I mean that was the point
wasn't it to wipe your ass okay so I
don't look don't look
Danny don't look alright Danny go go
crazy it's a law it's a little hard but
drink a lot of water I really have to go
people are waiting to tee off man
there's no restroom out here I drank a
lot of water and now man it ain't gonna
echo Roman man don't worry I've got
the perfect gift for you introducing the
uroclub
the discreet sanitary solution for your
urgent relief created by a
board-certified urologist what a board
board-certified created by a
board-certified urologist a urologist is
a physician who has specialized
knowledge and skill regarding problems
of male and female urinary tract well if
that's your specialty then I understand
your boredom I rely really do but it
contains a special reservoir built into
the grip to relieve yourself the Europe
office of the special towel to keep your
privacy
[Music]
well the real question is can you swing
it you know can you swing that club
after you dipped it in pit does it add
you know does it will it cover my hook
you know I've been having some cooking a
lot will it fix that problem
Terry leak-proof easy to clean and no
more embarrassing moments in the book
just pee in the bush just paying the
bush you're paying in a golf club at
Stella Bush bush dramatically improve
your golf scores for only forty nine
ninety five how how will that
dramatically increase my golf score
please please specify what the
you're talking about the euro club the
only Club in your bag guaranteed to keep
you out of the woods if you are a guy
you don't have this problem you can you
could just pee in the bush you could
just be in the bush you just go off and
let you off in the bush and if
you're at a nice golf course they will
have bathrooms they will have bathrooms
just go at those thank you
where did I park my car oh no and finer
actors you really have to look for where
where did I park my car I am unseparable
pain because where where did I park my
car now there's an easy way to remember
everything it's called my little
reminder the digital voice recorder that
records without tape blue section row 8
and then reminds you later or slip one
on your key range and you'll remember
everything that's left on Main Street
then go to miles so easy keep telling me
what a GoPro that's left on Main Street
then go 2 miles and write on a note have
you heard of a piece of paper a piece of
a piece of paper have you heard of it a
piece of paper a paper a piece of paper
what do all women look at when buying
Jean's oh my god you know this is gonna
be good
what do all women look at when buying
Jean's that's right there's
you're not so sexy bottoms imagine being
able to reshape your backside and
achieve that ultimate shapely lifted
whoa instantly Wow it's here Hollywood's
hottest new troe away what the just
like the padded bra enhances Birnbaum
nicing women's undergarment 35 now you
can get that fabulous figure that
bootylicious perky pop oh my god
where did we go wrong where did we go
wrong as a species now you can have that
super sexy booty just like the
celebrities boost your bottom and jeans
shorts dresses and more introducing
double wag giggle ball blog a wag
Campbell that makes the most hilarious
Oh hilarious for just $14.99 to make
this the funnest deal on TV okay Edgar
gonna be an annoying anymore
your I hate you shut the
up here it is that the wiggle the
wiggle ball he's looking at it
wobble wag giggle
oh my god he's crazy I never heard him
make these sounds
that's great
okay alright enough with the wig oppa
that's right good that's right oh hey
now from there we go box no you don't
control me
bye you can get to wobble wag giggle
ball for one low price of just $14.99
it's the problem in the marriage bed
that no one likes to talk about maybe
that's why they call it silent but
deadly
what well now there's a real solution to
a very real problem
introducing the better marriage blanket
yeah no I imagine you know the number
one reason for divorces the number one
cost is farting underneath the bed
iiiiii divorced Frank because that
kept farting over 100
million Americans keep guns in there
what home backup protection bed sign
shotgun oh seven million Americans keep
guns asks for protection the Second
Amendment to the Constitution guarantees
all Americans the word yeah their arms
but these arms must be accessible the
defective product is that the product is
that at your bedside and is easily
hidden by blankets and sheets the
patented backup device slides easily
that's a terrible idea
gun in a nightstand there is a solution
the patent-pending gun bat holy
there is a solution the patent the
connection boy bed is quite possibly the
biggest breakthrough in home defense
since the invention of the firearm hell
yeah and expensive introducing zoomies
but very high power binocular glasses
those who look cool instant three
hundred percent man crayon dread holding
heavy binoculars is tiring on your arms
and heavy on your neck but zoomies
binoculars yes like I call it yes the
smile why buy a big-screen TV when you
can just get the zoomies the zoomies
let's try out the zoomies I'm excited
for this one the whole packaging really
screams quality up did they say
300% magnification instant 300%
magnification here it says 400% did I
get the better version or 400% Frank's
face my god hell yeah
do I look cool I can't see myself it's
impossible yes and I can adjust whoa I
can adjust on the fly it's so smooth
it's not stuck at all it's so the thing
it's like the eyes are so tiny that you
basically see like you're looking
through a little pooper hole
[Music]
being a big guy certainly has its
advantages and its disadvantages the
future is here this is amazing